Typically, whenever we're working
with an existing Gradle project,
we'll be using the wrapper,
because that way we can ensure that
everyone working on the project is
using the same version of Gradle.
For our purposes however, it'd be a bit
of a pain to generate the Gradle wrapper
scripts for
every single one of these folders, so,
we'll have you use a local
installation instead.
You can find these instructions in the
course repository under
1.02-Exercise-InstallGradle.
These instructions will have you first
check that you have got a working Java
installation and
then we'll walk you through
the process of installing Gradle.
Note that if you're on Mac and
you are a Homebrew user, that's
a very easy way to install Gradle.
Also on Mac, there is the GVM,
the Groovy Environment Manager, and
that will also automatically
install Gradle for you.
Those are some good
options to check out.
So let's walk through the process
of installing Gradle manually.
First let's check that we have
a working Java installation.
Looks like we're good to go here.
If you don't have a working Java
installation there are instructions for
how to install that in
the course repository.
Now we need to download Gradle.
Head on over to
Gradle.org/downloads to do so.
We want the complete distribution.
Once we have the Gradle complete
distribution downloaded,
we need to do a bunch of other
things to get Gradle installed.
We need to move it to an appropriate
place on our machine, our suggestion is
user local Gradle, and then we also
need to add a few environment variables.
You can do all of this by yourself,
however, if you just paste in this
giant block of script into your console,
that'll do it all automatically.
All right, here goes nothing.
There we go.
Gradle has been extracted to user local
Gradle, and now we're ready to rock.
By the way,
if that last command complained,
you might need to run it with sudo.
All right.
Let's see if Gradle installed correctly.
Hey, there we go, that's looking good.
Gradle 2.3, ready for action.